pour parler de cet événement l'un des
ces lignes les plus passionnés sans
doute du moment merci d'être avec nous
fabrice luchini première question
d'abord et pourquoi votre amour votre
passion pour céline ça c'est peu
indéfinissable c'est un livre que j'ai
lu quand j'avais 20 ans et qui s'est
inscrit qui a raisonné comme si c'était
pas de la littérature comme si en lisant
je trouvais pas un univers imaginaire
omanaise dans des châteaux dans un
univers que je connais pas c'était un
roman qui pénétrait dans le réalisme le
plus atroce de la banlieue des rues sans
aucun pittoresque sans aucun populisme
et en même temps son génie c'est qu'ils
tapent aux nerfs sans être dans un
délire imaginaire est difficile pourquoi
on aime cet écrivain parce que parce que
ce serait trop long à expliquer je sais
pas pourquoi
simplement c'est un immense écrivain
vous allez acheter le manuscrit cet
après midi vous allez mettre beaucoup de
sous sur la table toujours frimer en
disant que je vais essayer de me mettre
dans les concurrents mais chargée pour
avoir un fantasme quelques secondes de
jeu des uns peut faire le côté rentrés
dans la dans la vente qu'il y avait 3 3
4 chaises où l'on puisse me dire
monsieur vous êtes asti ainsi là et que
pendant quelques secondes j'ai
l'impression de pouvoir pendant quelques
secondes
vaguement lever la main mais si ça
dépasse 4 je reste totalement neutre 4
millions oui quatre missiles en trois
quarts d'heure est quand même la vente
pendant une heure maintenant 4 millions
c'est votre chiffre je sais pas en tout
cas ça après ça serait immoral c'est
déjà immoral mais ben je sorte qu'on
sent dans l'absolu on s'en fout de tout
ça le fait que les mots qu'on s'en faut
parce que celui qui va acheter le
manuscrit dans quelques minutes ou dans
une heure il aura quoi il aura le
miracle de comprendre que ce qu'il va
avoir dans les mains ce manuscrit qui va
peut-être être vendu 2 3 4 5 6 7 je ne
sais pas
c'est le dernier brouillon avant le
miracle des miracles c'est celui là
c'est le livre de poche à 25 francs ou à
30 francs soit 40 francs quand je les ai
vus dans les malles manuscrits je me
suis rendu compte que tout était là mais
que le
irak n'étaient pas là ce tu as vendu
céline c'est pas du tout le dernier
livre il a vendu un dernier brouillon
mais il ya un moment miraculeux entre
ces deux moments là c'est que celui qui
l'a vendue sais pas du tout ce qu'on lit
canton quand moi je joue à la gaîté
montparnasse l'arrivée à new york jeudi
des phrases qui sont pas dans le
manuscrit qui sont presque dans le
manuscrit
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre le
manuscrit est la dernière chose qui est
le livre ce que je dis moi le soir au
théâtre la question c'était quoi la
question la question c'est la question
c'était la question je m'en souviens
plus si vous aviez une question je vous
laisse écouter je me souviens vous avez
un truc
d'habitude ils ont un lit quoi les
prompteurs oui non là il ya pas de
valeur pour parler avec vous il ya pas
de compteur je voulais parler du génie
de céline est de savoir en particulier
si c'est pas très difficile de le dire
je crois que c'est audiard un jour qui
avait dit par exemple céline on peut pas
le dire on veut pas loupé on veut pas
énoncer les mots et vous pourtant vous
le faites à la gaîté montparnasse en
particulier à partir du 1er juin vous
recommencez c'est ça mais c'est
compliqué il son génie à céline c'est
d'avoir retranscrit d'avoir le génie de
céline il est sain en fait c'est simple
une des grandes choses de céline à part
en plus c'est un tempérament romanesque
ça c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
emmanuel berl malraux
beaucoup de gens ont reconnu que c'était
le grand tempérament romanesque avec
proust bon ça c'est un peu un lieu
commun mais c'est vrai mais une chose
étonnante chez céline c'est qu'il a
restitué dans la langue écrite l'émotion
du langage parlé
attention va se calmer lorsque j'étais
en train de me dire en vous écoutant les
gens qui sont en train soit des jeunes
et de sai oui on voit des gens s'agiter
en train de lire le manuscrit va
peut-être partir vous rendez compte
il imagine un mec et lakiha 7000 deux
mois maximum au mensuel du cnam foot moi
que ça parte là ou pas là on en a rien à
cirer faut essayer de comprendre que
pourquoi il ya un fétichisme autour de
ça donc j'en viens à ma première réponse
sur le génie de céline l'émotion de la
langue parlée dans la langue écrite
alors on va pas faire de cours mais la
langue écrite à la place si la vitalité
de l'émotion à un moment avant que la
télé prennent cette puissance laquelle
nous écraserons nous accablant pas
toujours mais souvent il y avait une
vitalité dans l'oralité des gens parlent
les hommes parlaient entre eux visent
avait pas des codes qui sont
anéantissant il avait une vitalité il y
avait une émotion il y avait des grands
comptes et des gens qui prenaient la
parole et l'émotion de cette force orale
était perdue quand les gens écrivaient
est à jour
céline l'écrivain louis ferdinand céline
en 1932 pont un lit qu'ils appellent le
voyage au bout de la nuit et se livre à
cette seconde l'a fait cas on dirait que
c'est extrêmement écrit extrêmement
parler comment il fait parce que c'est
comment il fait comment ça se fait que
on a l'impression que son style est
comme de l'oralité alors que c'est écrit
alors le problème pour celui qui doit le
jouer au théâtre
c'est d'abord c'est pas ils n'avaient
pas prévu bien que sa femme est écrit
dans le bouquin qu'il avait quand même
espérer qu'un jour ça serait dit mais
c'est pas évident de laura lisez puisque
c'est une langue écrite mais
effectivement si je faisais proulx je
sens que vous en avez un peu bas dans
ses choix z rousse si je faisais proust
et ben ça ferait pas aussi efficace pour
une surprise le spectacle commence comme
ça par exemple pour une surprise s'en
foutent une à travers la brume c'était
tellement étonnant ce qu'on découvrait
soudain que nous nous refusons d'abord à
y croire et puis tout de même comme ou
fumant plein devant les choses tout
galériens qu'on était pas ce qui revient
d'afrique ont ceni a bien rigolé en
voyant ça droit devant nous figurez vous
qu'elle était debout leur ville
absolument droite
new york c'est une ville debout on en
avait déjà vu nous des villes bien sûr
et des belles encore et des ports et des
femmes eux mêmes mais chez nous n'est ce
pas elles sont couchés les villes au
bord de la mer ou sur les fleuves
elle s'allonge sur le paysage attendent
le voyageur tandis que celle là
l'américaine elle ne se pas mais pas un
an elle se tenait bien réel a pas besoin
du tout on voit qu à les accélérer
on voit que c'est peut-être orale vous
en avez marre si ça brise pas du tout
faye et si un jour antenne de réellement
devient fort face à m6 et qui réalise
une au lieu d' enfermer des gens dans un
vieux loft désespérant où les pauvres
sont la pathétique en train de se auto
sacrifier comme dans un espèce de rite
rond
mince c'est génial on est en train de
demander à des gens dénonça les balances
le lco mais la meuf elle dit ouais il
n'est pas sympa etc
et si un jour on avait vraiment du temps
donc je pense que ce qui va se vendre
dans quelques minutes
c'est un énorme témoignage de comment un
miracle arrive d'une dernier brouillon
un chef-d'oeuvre inexplicable gerra
merci à fabrice avoir été avec nous au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse de
toute façon à partir du 1er juin est en
tournée à partir du mois d'octobre
c'est vrai c'est ça oui on va se régaler
qui a du bon rendez vous tout à l'heure
vous qu'est ce qu'on va suivre la vente
aux enchères un rendez-vous la vente aux
enchères tout à l'heure à drouot ça me
fait plaisir
sifaoui merci beaucoup de votre journal
vous donner un dynamisme il ferait
vitale 2 à ses passions alors par les
draps merci au théâtre oui